In the last video on the
nephron, we talked about the
different parts of the nephron
and what, I guess, molecules
are reabsorbed by the body
and the different parts.
If you remember, in the proximal
convoluted tubule, we
talked about maybe glucose and
amino acids and sodium being
reabsorbed.
We talked about the ascending
part of the loop of Henle.
We talked about salts, so that
sodium, potassium, chlorine
being reabsorbed.
In the distal convoluted
tubule, it was
calcium, other things.
But at least in my mind, when I
first learned it, I said how
does that happen?
How do we actively pump out
these things, especially
against their own concentration
gradients?
What I want to do in this video
is get a little bit more
depth on exactly what's
happening on the borders of
these tubules to actually
allow these ions to be
selectively transported out of
the lumen or the inside of
these tubes or to be
reabsorbed out of the filtrate.
The mechanism's actually
reasonably similar in the
different parts of the nephron,
but let's look at
each of the parts, because
they're each reabsorbing
different types of molecules.
And I won't go through all of
the molecules, but I'll just
give you a sense of things.
Let's start with the proximal
tubule right here.
So let's say if we were to zoom
in right over on that
part-- so let me draw the
inside of the nephron.
The inside of the nephron
maybe looks
something like this.
So this the inside.
This is where our filtrate
is right here.
Actually, let me draw
it a little bit
different than that.
So the inside, I'm going to draw
it like this because the
proximal tubule has these little
things that stick out,
sometimes referred to
as a brush border.
So this inside right here,
this is our lumen.
That is where the filtrate is.
The glomerular filtrate is
coming in this direction.
This is, you can imagine, the
inside of the nephron.
And then the border of
the tubule is made up
by a bunch of cells.
So maybe this is one cell right
here, this is another
cell right here, that's
another cell.
Obviously, this is
a cross-section.
It would be actually
more of a cylinder.
It would go around like that.
This is to give an idea.
That's another cell
right there.
And maybe this is their basal
side right there.
And when we say basal, we can
imagine that's kind of the
base of the cell.
Those are good words to
know, fancy words.
So the side of the cells that
are facing the lumen, or kind
of facing the inside of our
tubule, this is called the
apical side.
And then this side is normally
referred to the basal lateral
side, or this membrane, if you
view this as a membrane, this
would be the basolateral
membrane.
This is true regardless of what
part of the nephron we're
in, whether the proximal,
whether the loop of Henle, or
whether we're in the
distal part.
What we have here, and on the
other sides of these cells,
we'll have our peritubular
capillaries.
That's another fancy word.
So our peritubular capillaries
will look something like this.
They're actually
cells as well.
Actually, instead of drawing the
cells, I'll just draw it
as kind of the tube of-- I'll
just draw it like this.
They're porous.
So this is actually blood
flow right here.
This is blood right here.
I'm not going to do too much
detail on the actual cells of
the capillary walls.
I really want to give you the
idea of how things are
transported out of the lumen,
how they're selectively
reabsorbed.
So this is the peritubular
capillary.
And once again, fancy
word, but peri means
around, like perimeter.
So it's around the tubes.
These capillaries go
around the tubes.
If I were overlay it on this
picture, we have these
capillaries that are going
all around the tubes.
So when things get secreted
or reabsorbed out of the
nephrons, they're going into
those capillaries.
So this is our proximal
convoluted
membrane right here.
Let's think about what happens
with the glucose.
So what happens is we actually
have sodium-potassium pumps on
the basolateral side
of these cells.
So this is sodium-potassium
pumps.
I'll just draw one right here.
You might want to watch
the video on
sodium-potassium pumps.
I have a whole video on it.
But the idea here is that
sodium, maybe I'll draw as
plus particles right there,
they'll attach on the inside
right here, ATP will
come along.
When ATP attaches to the right
part of this protein, it'll
change its shape, its
conformation, and then the
protein will essentially close
on this side and open on that
side, and then when it's in that
conformation, the sodium
doesn't want to bond as much to
the protein and it will go
outside or it'll cross the
basolateral membrane and
eventually make its way
into the blood.
And then on the other side, it's
a sodium-potassium pump.
When it's in this kind of open
configuration-- I'll draw it
over here; I have a whole video
on this-- at that point,
potassium likes to bond to it.
So potassium likes
to bond to it.
Maybe it bonds to
it over here.
This is a gross
oversimplification.
That causes the protein to
change its conformation.
It doesn't require ATP at that
point, and it goes back to
this conformation, and then the
potassium doesn't want to
bond anymore, and then it gets
released, because the protein
is now a different shape.
So the general idea:
Sodium bonds.
ATP bonds.
The ATP gets its phosphate
popped off of it.
That changes the shape of
the protein to this.
Now the sodium wants to get
released, and now potassium
wants to join.
When potassium joins, we get
to our original one.
The end product of this is
we're having sodium being
pumped out of the cell and we're
having potassium being
pumped into the cell, and this
is active transport.
Why is it active transport?
Because we're using ATP to
drive sodium against its
concentration gradient to keep
pumping the sodium out of the
cell, and then potassium kind of
comes in, you could almost
imagine, passively.
It doesn't require ATP.
And that's why this is often
called a sodium-potassium
ATPase, which means it's a
protein or an enzyme that
breaks ATP.
But it breaks ATP, it uses
that energy to change its
shape to pump sodium out
and potassium in.
Well, anyway, this is all a
review of what we learned in
those videos, but how does that
help us, for example, get
glucose out of our lumen?
Well, what we have over here
is we have other proteins.
I'll just do the example
of glucose.
Let's say we have
a protein here.
There's a very general
term for this.
It's a cotransporter
or a symporter.
Symporter means it transfers two
types of molecules in the
same direction.
Cotransporter means one molecule
wants to go through
because of its concentration
gradient and the other
molecule kind of goes
along for the ride.
So you can imagine, we're
actively pumping out sodium.
So if we're actively pumping
out sodium over here on the
basolateral side, then we're
going to have a low sodium
concentration here.
The more we pump out, the lower
this is, and eventually
it's going to be lower
than the sodium
concentration in the lumen.
So the sodium concentration
gradient, if there was no
membrane here, sodium would want
to go across this to kind
of make up for all of the
lost sodiums over here.
Sodium would want to cross that
if there was no barrier.
These cells here take advantage
of sodium wanting to
move down its concentration
gradient, which is happening
because of this active transport
over here, but it
uses that energy of sodium going
down its concentration
gradient to actually also
transport, in this case, maybe
some glucose.
So if you had to visualize it,
you could imagine a protein
that's on this apical
membrane right here.
Maybe it looks something
like this.
This is to get some type
of visualization.
Maybe you have more sodium on
this side than you have on
this side, so sodium is more
likely to bond here.
Maybe glucose will bond here.
This is just a simplification,
but when they bond, this
protein is going to change its
shape to look something more
like this when they bond, and
now the sodium is going to be
here and the glucose is
going to be here.
We're essentially on the inside
of the cell now, and in
this conformation, they don't
want to bond as much to the
amino acids or whatever else
is in the protein, and then
they get released.
And when they get released, then
the protein will change
its shape back to this right
here and we can do this cycle
over again.
But this is all stipulated on
the idea that there's more
sodium over here to bump into
this point to make this
reaction happen.
So sodium's going to go down in
its concentration gradient.
It's taking glucose
for the ride.
And so essentially glucose
concentration will go up high
here, and then if we make this
porous to glucose so glucose
can go through, then glucose
will eventually, if this gets
high enough, it'll just go
down its concentration
gradient eventually
into the blood.
And this same exact process is
happening, maybe not exactly
with glucose, but throughout
the entire nephron.
If we go to the loop of Henle,
if we go to the ascending part
right here, where we're trying
to get the salts out of the
picture, same idea.
So let's say that that right
there is the lumen.
This is a cell that makes up
the wall of the lumen.
We're in the loop of Henle
now and you have a
sodium-potassium
pump out here.
You have sodium being
pumped out.
You have potassium gets pumped
in, but actually, potassium
channels are leaky, so potassium
can often make its
way back out in either
direction.
So what's happening to
potassium isn't that important.
But so sodium concentration
becomes low here.
So what we have are symporters
over here, just like we had
with glucose, but in this case,
sodium wants to enter
just as the case with glucose,
but here we're trying to
transport chlorine and
potassium ions.
So that's what we're
going to join.
That's what's going to take
advantage of sodium's
concentration gradient.
We're going to have potassium
and we're going to have
chlorine ions.
And actually, this symporter
right here, it's called the
sodium-potassium-chlorine
cotransporter, and it's
actually the second variation
that you actually get in the
ascending loop of Henle.
So eventually, you're going to
end up with a lot of chlorine
here-- actually, potassium from
both directions-- but as
long as this is porous
to chlorine, if this
concentration gets high enough,
the chlorine is going
to make its way out and help
make the medulla that much
saltier along with the sodium.
Same thing in the distal
convoluted tubule.
There, calcium.
It's a little bit different.
So if we're in the distal
convoluted tubule, these kind
of villi, these things that
stick out-- this is only in
the proximal convoluted tubule,
those brush borders.
But over there-- and just so
you know, this idea where
we're using a concentration
gradient that's driven by some
type of active transport to
transport other things, this
is called secondary
active transport.
That's nice to know.
And then just finishing up at
the distal convoluted tubule.
So this was the lumen.
Let's say that this is the lumen
right here, so we have
cells on either side of that.
I think you get the
general idea.
The distal's a little bit
different so let's say this is
a cell, and let's say that
this is a peritubular
capillary right here.
This is our blood.
What we have here is
once again, we're
pumping sodium out.
Sodium-potassium pumps.
I have a whole video on that,
and that pumps potassium in,
so you end up with a lot
of sodiums over here.
The apical membrane that
faces the lumen,
it's porous to calcium.
Whatever the concentration
of calcium here,
it's going to be here.
So maybe you have calcium.
These are calcium ions just
like that floating around.
And right here, what you
have is an antiporter.
So our concentration in the
blood of sodium is going to be
higher because we keep
pumping it out.
And so sodium, if you let it
go down its concentration
gradient, it would go back in.
And so maybe right here you have
some sodium going down,
its concentration gradient going
back in, and then when
that goes in, that you can
almost imagine it's some type
of a rotating door, it makes
the calcium go out.
You can try to visualize it
yourself how a protein would
actually do that.
I kind of imagine a
revolving door.
The sodium makes the
door revolve.
The calcium is at the other
part of the door and
it gets spit out.
So this is called an antiporter
because they're
going in different directions,
but once again, it's secondary
active transport, because the
only way that this could work
is if we have active transport
using ATP of the sodium out of
the basolateral membrane in
every one of these cases.
Anyway, hopefully, you
found that useful.
It's more detailed than you
normally get on how the
nephron is actually pumping
things out of the lumen into
the peritubular capillaries, but
for me, it made things a
lot more concrete.
It helps me really kind of
internalize what the
nephron is up to.